hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages
as they arrive over the next half an
hour we're going to be talking through
the headlines with the director of the
demos think tank polly mckenzie
and the journalist and chair of the
bright blue think tank sarah sand so a
very good evening to both of you
so let's take a look then on what's
making the front pages and the eye leads
with nhs staff
insisting they'll strike if the
government doesn't increase its offer
of a one percent pay rise the mirror
describes the proposal as
boris's slap for carers likewise the
star
appears to suggest the prime minister's
applause last year
was a hollow gesture indeed the guardian
understands there will be a slow hand
clap next thursday
by way of a protest and that row over
nhs pay is also the big story
for the express the daily telegraph
reports that from monday people
attempting to travel out of britain and
onto the continent
will need to produce forms to prove
their journey is essential
the times have spoken to the head of an
influential scientific group who
believes the presence of new covert 19
variants in the uk
will not hinder a return to normality
the financial times have seen data which
shows a substantial drop in trade
between france and the uk
at the start of the year which the paper
says is largely down to brexit
and the daily mail has a story regarding
the controversy over who
is paying for planned renovations to the
flat above number 10 downing street
so polly mackenzie and sarah sands here
with me to go through some of those
front pages
and polly you picked out the i first of
all but there are a lot of similar
headlines around in the morning aren't
they
focusing in on the government's offer of
a one percent
pay rise to nhs staff which has been met
with a pretty angry reaction
from unions
yeah it's interesting to see so many of
the papers lining up to criticize the
government on this
and you know there's actually some
strong arguments for a minimal pay rise
uh the private sector has had you know
massive impact on
on pay during this period so the
government's making the case that
public sector pay overall should be
frozen and they're making an exception
they think they're being very
generous to the nhs by giving it one
percent when everybody else is getting
nothing
actually inflation is still pretty low
though in the budget the chancellor
forecasted some inflationary pressures
so that might change nevertheless
it's not you know it's not wildly out of
step with
inflation and of course lots of people
in the nhs
get pay increments every year so their
pay goes up more and it averages out
about
2.7 not one percent once you've added in
those increments
nevertheless it doesn't look good and
you can see the papers ganging up they
see political weakness
the nurses it's always the lightning rod
as nurses even though actually they're
not the worst paid in the nhs
the worst paid will be reporters and
nursing assistants
um the doctors don't get quite so much
simply plus they have a different pay
band but nevertheless
it will be about the nurses the nurses
are threatening to go on strike and i
forecast that in the end
this government which caves on
everything will cave
that's interesting i'll pick up on that
straight away actually uh with you sarah
sands do you think this could be another
marcus rashford moment as some people
are suggesting
it's looking like it isn't i mean they
started with a sort of economic argument
you know
firstly the country's bust and second um
as as uh paulie said that the pro in the
private sector a lot of jobs have gone
so that trying to make people think that
at least these are secured jobs and that
um actually there will be more jobs as
we know in in health
um but it's just it's just not working
you know you
just don't take on nurses um and i
wonder if they're just looking for some
way out i mean it it did occur to me
that you could make the um
equivalent with what happens during
during wartime actually is that
soldiers can get such a special combat
pay and this has been a kind of war and
nurses have been on the front line so i
wonder if they could come up with some
sort of special payment but they're
certainly going to have to come up with
something
well yes and to pick up on another paper
that's covering the story in a similar
way the guardian
nurses threaten strikers hancock defends
pay offer
but we have of course heard matt hancock
haven't we apolly
several times talking about the need to
reward nhs staff in fact on
sky sophie ridge on sunday he said last
july we absolutely want to reward
nhs staff for what they've done so
what are the political implications for
getting into some kind of a battle
with nhs staff who have been widely
praised
by cabinet members and the prime
minister themselves for the work they've
done
i think it's potentially politically
risky
you know nurses are you know everybody
loves nurses everybody loves the nhs we
clap for carers we put rainbows in our
windows
it is the national religion basically
and picking a fight is dangerous
um but also there's a kind of pragmatic
case that actually if nurses do go on
strike
that inevitably though they will
continue always to support
emergency care it does have an impact
creates a backlog for elective care
things like
hip operations or diagnosis scans and
tests
and we've already got the motherload of
backlogs as a result of this year of
covid
and so much of the nhs happening to be
restricted or shut down
so we know that the tories are always
vulnerable on the nhs it's
you know people trust them on the
economy but not so much on public
services
if the nhs gets into a really really
difficult situation
that that's a huge political
vulnerability for them a strike would
just
worsen all of the problems which the nhs
is already facing
and sarah it's just a days away from
from the budget of course do you think
there will be
some public sympathy for the government
line that that says
remember the budget we heard how bad the
economy the state that it's in just a
couple of days ago they we
saw that it had record levels of debt
that there's a tax burden that we
haven't seen since the 1960s we could
only pay
what we can afford and this is about
retaining jobs as well
seemingly not that if you look at those
public opinion polls and people want
nurses to be paid considerably more and
certainly on this seem to be
entirely sympathetic so i think um the
trouble with
with uh big spending is that people
start to get used to it and
and make comparisons think so much
already
um you know why not just um bung in a
bit more you know to people who deserve
it so i think
um to have to sort of retrain people um
out of um
you know the currents at keynesian um um
economics is is going to take a little
time well yes
and polly this is the offer that the
government is putting forward it now
goes to
an independent panel that will decide uh
what they think that the pay rise
should be and what about this this issue
of staffing because
although i think the pandemic has
prompted more people to come forward to
say that they want to be nurses there is
a big shortfall there's a number of
vacancies aren't there
across the board do you think that could
be taken into consideration when pay is
considered
how attractive it makes the job
i think it has to be you know there's
there's two cases for paying
nurses but nhs staff more broadly more
the first is a natural justice one and
you know we've seen in scotland
the scottish government has made a kind
of a one-off payment a bonus a gratitude
bonus
and there's people advocating in england
that we should do the same
the other argument is a simply pragmatic
one about demand and supply
in the labor market how do you get
people to do these jobs we had huge
numbers of vacancies in the run-up to
the pandemic
a lot of foreign-born people have it
seems from the data
gone home during this pandemic homes are
loaded word but they've
gone back to another country um and they
may or may not come back we may have
lost up to a million people from our
population
so the pressure it to recruit people
into the nhs when people are you know so
many will feel burnt out and exhausted
by this experience
you know we may find that we have to put
wages up
in order to recruit and retain the
volumes of nurses and doctors and care
workers that we need
in the system because the really
vulnerable the vulnerable group is
care workers in the social care system
we're not really talking about them
they don't have that hero status of the
nhs they're mostly in the private sector
they're often on the minimum wage
they're often on not even full
employment contracts and actually if the
government was to do something
uh there i think it would have much more
of an impact certainly on
the quality of the system regardless of
exactly where the politics lie
and sarah finally let's look at a couple
of front pages which treat the story in
a similar kind of way i would say
i don't know what you think daily mirror
um calls it boris's slap for carers of
course of reference to clap for carers
and the daily star as well i mean it's
rather a long quotation they've got on
the front there or the wrong headline
they say
i'm not giving them a decent pay rise
but do you think they'd settle for
another clap suggesting that's what the
prime minister is saying
what do what will downing street make of
that kind of coverage i mean
presumably they've been um cheered by
the fact
that um the polls suggest that the
tories are
doing a bit better because of the
success of the vaccination program
will they be worried about headlines
like this i'm sure they will i think the
express as well has
taken them on which you wouldn't
necessarily expect so i think
you're right they have they have had a
big bounce and they seem to be slightly
um
uh um a teflon effect at the moment um
that they have been doing pretty well so
i think um i think they weren't like
this at all
no indeed well we're going to take a
break right there but uh plenty more
to be discussed in just a moment after
the break when we're going to be talking
more about the pandemic but also
the glimmer of hope for a return to
normality more on that coming up after
the break
[Music]
i'm adam parsons i'm skye's europe
correspondent based here in brussels
more flares going off a volley of rocks
troubles have been pulled up out and
have been used as missiles of hell
at these police
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place
for news we have now
left italy and entered france nobody's
asked to check
our identity
[Music]
made by people who dare to challenge
nice to see you again mr barnier
disappointment why not meeting you
fishing does have the potential to
stymie
an enormous economic deal
what strikes you when you come to this
glacier is not just the way in which the
environment is changing
but the speed at which those changes are
happening
it's devastating actually
[Music]
so
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me tonight polly mckenzie
and
sarah sand so welcome back to both of
you and sarah we're kicking off this
section with the daily telegraph their
headline
says travel permits to stop easter
holidays
abroad and a lot of people are starting
to dream about some kind of holiday
so what's the telegraph talking about
what is potentially changing
uh well this is oddly punitive a little
bit police state
that uh you have to prove that um you're
on legitimate business if you if you go
away and the fines are going to go up
and i think what uh so at the same time
that vaccines are working and the
uh cases of covert are going down um
there seems to be sort of unease that
there might be a dividend or that people
might start to
um loosen up a little bit that those
over 70s might just start creeping
abroad there was that story this morning
about cyprus welcoming people who are
vaccinated from may
um so this is the government sort of
toughening up and
and cracking down and i think you just
have to watch that social contract a bit
that graeme brady
is already sort of complaining that you
know hang on this is a time where you
think restrictions are being lifted you
know things are getting better
covets going cases going down vaccines
are working
so you um you toughen up restrictions
and
on the other side there's um for that
exact reason that
um if if domestically things are getting
better that's when you
you close your borders it is interesting
the psychology of it probably isn't it
because on the one hand
people need to feel optimistic but the
government is clearly worried
that when they do start talking about
better times ahead everyone's just going
to relax
especially it would appear those who've
been vaccinated who thinks
surely it's okay that i can i can behave
a little bit in
a more relaxed way yeah exactly i mean
the
article says that they're particularly
worried about people who've been
vaccinated
meeting up with family and friends
jetting off on holiday whatever
it might be assuming they can get past
the border guards
and you know it's an odd situation that
we've got to that it's only now
just as we are hopefully on the exit
ramp that they're bothering to enforce
the laws
that they impose you know we had a
quarantine uh
last summer i remember where you know i
was coming back from france went through
the border guards nobody told me i had
to quarantine even though
i knew from the news that i had to
nobody gave me instructions nobody
called
you know and so they allowed us to have
rules that were most
uh honored in the breach than the um
the what's the word um you know what i
mean anyway um
for ages and now right at the last
minute they finally learned that it's
better to have
a small set of rules and enforce them
but um i i don't think this will
last i think it's getting harder and
harder to sustain public consent for
um for having to follow rules especially
when you see
you know people in care homes where the
elderly person has been vaccinated
and their visit has been vaccinated and
they're still having to
hide behind perspective screens it just
feels a bit wrong-headed well
and obviously the hope is that the
restrictions or tight restrictions
certainly won't be in place
for too much longer sarah and the times
kind of feeds that sense of optimism
doesn't it their headline says variants
will not hold uk backs as top scientists
because the
the one outlier p appears to be you know
this sense of possible new variants
potentially evading
vaccines in the future so what's the
times reporting here
yeah that is really good news that the
vaccine should work
on these variants and the variants
aren't taking over and i guess the point
of that was
was the fear that we would start to come
out of lockdown and then some variant
would
scupper it all and it looks as if um
it's under control
and that in the same way that flew the
family of flu should have worked
um with variants that this can happen in
the same way so that's a sort of
scientific confidence which
should please everyone it does still it
makes me wonder if that june date is
still too cautious and that they may
and they may be able to bring it forward
a bit i see boris johnson's going off to
india
um next month i think it's it's reported
somewhere
so um is that is that's not a holiday
though is it i don't know
where why is he going no that's
essential essential business
well he's got to fill out the form i
guess people are going to start to sort
of work things out for themselves as
police said on
you know those people who have been
vaccinated um where it is already
breaking down
and and older people are seeing each
other and um it's it's because you can't
really give us a rational explanation
why they shouldn't
um if they're not transmitting it and
they're not and they're protected
why can't they see each other you know
except that because
we're all in this together and i guess
that is another point that if
if um younger people who have you know
been denied their festivals and so on
um see a lot of older people sort of um
uh having their own over over 70s raised
they're going to get quite cross
yeah okay well we're out of time there
but uh polly and sarah really good to
see you both and i'm pleased to say
you'll be back at 11 30 for now thank
you
well before we go if you've missed any
of the press previews tonight or
the one we've just done it's going to be
available shortly and every night on our
youtube
channel